uh loser this is from the new album  Charlie this is a stripped down version  this is Jan and Charlie putting it  together for you right now live  [Music]  I use the piano  where's that Neil Young chord  [Music]  oh baby I must have been out of my mind  [Music]  I just might get a little too drunk so I  won't think about us  I don't think about  what could I feel and I stay up like  three or four nights so I won't dream  about us  I wake up with no luck I just can't win  I should have seen it all along she  wasn't wanting a million  it hurts whenever someone says her name  we were going off and on I guess I  really played it wrong I should have  never let her slip away  oh I'm such a loser  oh baby  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  tell me God is real do you think about  me still I Am I Living For Nothing  don't know where it went wrong but I'll  just take the hint  and it takes some adjusting oh I'm such  a loser how'd I ever lose  [Music]  [Music]  my  um  [Music]  beautiful boys